the raiders are now officially the las
vegas raiders it wasn't supposed to
happen until march
i don't know why the timetable was
accelerated but it was and it came
somewhat out of the blue yesterday
they've adopted the name las vegas from
oakland to l.a back to oakland to las
vegas there's derrick carr with the
mallet there pounding the sign into the
ground and uh derek carr feels like he's
been pounded into the ground with the
rumors of other quarterbacks taking over
for him most recently tom brady
attending the ufc fight in las vegas
photos of him talking to mark davis the
owner of the team prompting speculation
that the raiders may be on the list of
teams for which tom brady would play i
would love to see john gruden standing
on the third rung of a step stool trying
to get face-to-face with tom brady so he
could yell some f words at him i'm sure
that would go over extremely well but uh
look i i don't think brady is a viable
option for the raiders
the point here is derek carr
sees this
hears this and he's getting upset by
they had comments to espn.com
where basically said you know what else
do i have to do like why is this always
a story with me well if you were
tom brady if you were a true shortlist
franchise quarterback it wouldn't be a
story there are plenty of raiders fans
that would like to see the team find a
better quarterback chris well yeah i
mean and it's not necessarily like the
play of you derek carr
you know the play there was a lot to
like this year there was
you know the big thing is derek carr
first off you got to block all this crap
out of your mind this is not going to do
you any favors and to john gruden and
the coaching staff or you know really
anybody that's involved in football in
the oakland raiders
uh organization they're gonna look at
this and use this against you derek carr
that you're sensitive and that you read
all this stuff and they don't want that
they want a guy that just is fearless
and go and it's john gruden he's a
psycho you got to be a psycho back so
that's the first thing and we're saying
all these things right mike not because
of like necessarily again because of
derek carr's play but because we know
who the head coach is and the head coach
is for lack of a better phrase the
biggest quarterback we've ever seen i
mean that's just the way it is hello
hello on a thursday morning but that's
what he does i mean when i was there
every in tampa with john gruden every
off season i went all right what four
quarterbacks are we gonna bring in this
year how many are we gonna cram into our
small crappy quarterback room i mean
jeff garcia got there one year and he
made comments all through the offseason
you know gruden he loves the flirt he
loves to bring you know the hot girl to
the to the prom or whoever the the girl
he likes at that time has in like
quarterbacks that's just the way it is
there's always somebody new that fancies
gruden's eye that's why we say it it's
not necessarily personal against you
derek carr
i think he meant quarterback hoarder no
i meant
i meant i said it right
i threw you a lifeline for i don't need
a lifeline it doesn't matter screw that
lifeline that's just what i'm saying
uh look here's the thing
there's a there's a ceiling on what
derek carr can do and i think john
gruden knows it i think john gruden has
kind of restrained his nature the past
couple of years because he's concerned
that derek carr would crumble under the
full weight of what you experienced in
tampa with john gruden and i think he
wants somebody where he can be himself
and he wants somebody that he can make
into his next rich gannon and let me
tell you chris if the titans let ryan
tannehill get away that's the name i'm
watching for the raiders and i know
derek carr is not going to like that
either but i'd take ryan tan hill over
derek carr right now well i i mean i get
it i do tana hill's every bit as
talented as derek carr there's no doubt
about that andy's more athletic um but
you know yes you're right gruden i think
he doesn't want to look bad and like oh
i got a job and right away here i am i
don't get along with the quarterback and
have that reputation so he's trying to
suit that over but we know he'd led a
love affair for kyler murray last year
and everything like that so yeah i'm not
so sure derek carr is going to be the
starter yet we'll see we're going to all
be seeing
he's not on our guest list next week
we'll be right back
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports